[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ya des banquiers dans la
salle lever la main les banquiers ici
aussi mais pas tout seul on emile et
tous ensemble on a créé une monnaie une
monnaie c'est quoi ben c'est ça et bien
avec ce billet à la semaine dernière moi
j'ai voyagé et j'ai pu réserver une
chambre d'hôtel je suis rentré dans
l'hôtel rempli les papiers là les
papiers administratifs et je donne ce
biais au patron de l'hôtel et puis je
pars me balader en ville
le patron ne pas lui il dit je vais
aller boire un petit coup au café du
coin et puis je vais en profiter pour
régler mon ardoise
il va voir le patron du bar et il lui
donne le biais ça tombait bien parce que
le patron du bar il avait sa voiture a
récupéré chez le garagiste
donc il va chez le garagiste il récupère
sa voiture et ils lui donnent son billet
le garagiste lui il avait des dettes à
rembourser aux patrons de l'hôtel
alors il se dirige tranquillement vers
l'hôtel il va voir le patron et il lui
donne le billet alors c'est à ce moment
là que moi dans ma petite balade là je
me dis oui la semaine prochaine une
conférence tedx à chambéry ce serait
quand même bien que je sois un peu stage
que je rentre la préparer du coup je
retourne à l'hôtel je m'excuse auprès du
patron je lui dis que j'annule ma
réservation et donc le patron de l'hôtel
ne me donnes le billet ce biais
bien c'était un faux ce bienne avait de
la valeur que parce que les gens qui
l'ont utilisé penser qu'il en avait la
monnaie c'est une histoire de confiance
alors parlant monnaie si je vous dis le
yen le dollar l'euro la livre sterling
peut-être même le franc cfa je pense que
vous voyez de quoi je peux maintenant si
je vous dis là ghosn est le ch kof le
sol violette la roue le king hour le
palmas le kern le léman il existe des
milliers de monnaie qui circulent dans
le monde
en complément de celles que vous
connaissez ces monnaies complémentaires
elles répondre à d'autres besoins que
les grandes monnaies nationales et
internationales et bien par exemple ce
soir on est à chambéry et la monnaie
qu'on a créé nous c'est en complément de
l'euro c'est l'élève est l'élève cette
monnaie
c'est simple je vais dans un comptoir de
change de l'association la monnaie
autrement je sors un billet de 10 euros
celui-là c'est c'est un vrai et puis je
le change contre dix élèves
à partir de là c'est simple j'ai le
choix chambéry c'est une agglo de 120
mille habitants j'ai près de 200
professionnels qui acceptent l'élève est
donc avec ce billet en poche je peux
faire un peu ce que je veux moi je
décide d'aller barre à boire un coup
dans un bar du centre-ville qu'ils
l'acceptent et bien en discutant avec la
patronne et en voyant un peu son petit
sourire quand elle m'a vu sortir mes
billets d'élèves
je me suis dit quand même que c'était
vraiment génial que payer en élèves
soient devenus aussi simple que de payer
avec une carte sans contact
en plus elle me dit maintenant moi je
reçois des paiements en élève quasiment
tous les jours et elle me dit qu'elle a
remarqué un truc c'est que les gens qui
la paye en élève il discute plus avec
elle de tout de rien de la vie du
quartier
mais à l'écouter je me suis dit que en
fait c'est comme si ça a donné encore
plus de valeur à cette monnaie et puis
maintenant avec les élèves qu'elle a
encaissé
elle achète sa bière en local auprès
d'un brasseur qu'elle a découverte parce
qu'il a accepté aussi l'élève et puis
aussi une partie du salaire de sa
serveuse qu'elle paye en et l'oeuf et la
serveuse holtz d'ubs en fait c'est sympa
ça me tous les mois je découvre des
nouvelles boutiques dans lesquels je
serai peut-être jamais allé en fait ça
se fait de plus en plus même les mairies
smet
il y avait déjà en angleterre le maire
de la commune de brixton qui avait
décidé d'accepter l'intégralité de son
indemnité d'élue en monnaies locales en
brixton parle
eh bien nous il ya des élus ici qu'ils
ont dit en fin d'année les bons cadeau
qu'on offre à nos agents municipaux
on va les verser en élève mais parce que
comme ça ça va encourager les gens à les
dépenser dans les petits commerces du
coin quand on quand même bien besoin par
les temps qui courent et puis du coup
bas cette monnaie elle continuera de
circuler il avait bien compris sahel
sévère s'évaporera pas loin de la ville
en fête en quittant ce bar là je me suis
senti quand même vraiment fier de me
dire
les deux élèves que j'avais laissé au
comptoir pour mon café
il allait rejoindre les 100000 déjà en
circulation qui se balade un peu partout
je crois qu'il ya un truc que j'adore
vraiment c'est de me dire que avec cette
monnaie je retrouve le pouvoir de tout
mon argent va enfin plutôt où il va plus
c'est à dire très loin de chez moi à
l'autre bout de la planète dans les
paradis fiscaux ou pour financer des
activités extra polluantes et la
confiance est là h en mairie on n'a pas
fait les choses à moitié on n'a pas créé
une banque on en a créé 2 ben oui parce
que la monnaie on a dit c'est la
confiance et des échanges ya par exemple
l'unité de compte pour ça ça peut être
du temps
et qu'est-ce qu'on échange avec du temps
par exemple des services qu'on peut se
rendre les uns les autres
notre deuxième banque c'est le temps
c'est la corderie à l'accord de vie on
échange des heures des heures de service
une heure de repassage contre des heures
de cours d'informatique des heures de
pour tailler une haie contre des heures
pour se faire aider à remplir les
formulaires administratifs par exemple
une heure est égale à une heure quel que
soit le type de services échangés à la
corderie tous les talents ont la même
valeur
il ya une histoire qui s'est passé à la
corderie et qui moi m'a profondément
touché c'est celle d'une personne qui
avait rendu pas mal de services elle
avait gardé des enfants elle avait fait
du repassage et avec toutes les heures
qu'elle avait accumulé sur son compte
tant elle a demandé à plusieurs
personnes de venir chez elle et ils ont
repeint tout son appartement évidemment
elle était toute seule
ce chantier elles sentais complètement
incapable et en plus elle en avait pas
les moyens
ça s'est fait tasser fait les accordeurs
les accordeurs ce qu'ils disent et que
échanger sans argent ça les rend plus
égaux entre eux ils disent que s'il n'y
avait pas eu système 1 il ya tout un tas
de gens qu'ils auraient pas rencontré
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont pas du
même monde
ou parce qu'ils habitent pas le même
quartier ils disent la vraie richesse en
fait c'est les liens qui nous unissent
ils disent qu'en quand on sort du
système classique de l'euro ça nous rend
plus libres ils disent il serait quand
même urgent qu'on se mette à compter ce
qui compte vraiment dans nos vies parce
que quand on compte seulement en euro on
laisse de côté un sacré paquet de choses
qui ont de la valeur dans nos vies comme
l'amitié l'amour le bien-être la dignité
la reconnaissance et la confiance ne
doutez jamais qu'un petit groupe de gens
engagés et réfléchie puisse changer le
monde en fait c'est toujours comme ça
que ça s'est passé
bon ça c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
margaret mid l'anthropologue mais oui
parce qu'au départ on n'était pas 1000
ils étaient 15 joyeux déterminer tous
d'horizons assez différent mais il
voulait s'attaquer au nerf de la guerre
à l'argent il voulait que ça devienne le
nerf de la paix et pourtant aucun était
économiste encore moins banquiers ça
leur faisait même pas peur en fait ils
sont partis d'une idée simple il d'un
constat d'une réalité aujourd'hui à 98 %
des transactions monétaires qui se passe
sur les marchés spéculatifs et il y en a
seulement deux pour cent dans l'économie
réelle
les échanges de biens et de services et
bein euh c'était ses 2 % qui les
intéressait
en fait c'est simple c'était une bande
d'un peu de pragmatique concret donc ils
sont venus à la définition de base de ce
qu'est l'économie l'économie au sens
étymologique du terme c'est la gestion
de la maison du foyer ok ça c'est simple
tout le monde comprend ça veut dire
l'économie en fait c'est travailler
faire ses courses payer ses impôts
s'occuper de ses proches et ses ébats à
partir de cette idée là ils sont 10 mai
les richesses là elles sont dans tous
les aspects de nos vies
mais ce qui reste à faire là c'est de
les faire circuler et du coup ça a donné
tiens je serais quand même vraiment
chouette qu'on donne envie les uns les
autres de plus se rencontrer et puis de
céder la wii parce que dans les villes
dans lesquelles on vit aujourd'hui les
grandes villes on n'est plus dans des
villages on se connaît plus les uns les
autres même pas avec nos voisins voire
même des fois on a peur il y en a qui
l'ont dit avant moi et ben hop une
accorderies et puis il ya eu aussi tiens
ce serait quand même vraiment important
qu on s'encourage à jouer le jeu du
local dans nos achats
bah oui parce qu'on se rend bien compte
que pour que les villes elles soit sympa
à vivre dynamique attractive etc
il nous faut plein de petits commerces
locaux indépendants il faut que ça vive
quoi et puis il faut aussi des activités
économiques qui prennent soin notre
environnement
histoire qu'on leur pas tous de
pollution en plein hiver hop une monnaie
locale comme
c'est passé en fait vous connaissez
henry ford vous connaissez en uniforme
l'industriel américain le fordisme tout
ça ok bon et ben henry ford
il y avait un truc vachement intéressant
il disait ça rien avant que les voitures
d'ailleurs il disait si les gens de
cette nation comprenez notre système
monétaire et bancaire
je pense qu'il y aurait une révolution
avant demain matin
eh bien les monnaies locales ça sert
aussi à comprendre l'économie mais je
pourrais vous faire le plus beau
powerpoint du monde pour vous expliquer
je suis parmi les mécanismes de la
création monétaire ou les institutions
de la banque centrale européenne ou
encore les cycles de la crise depuis les
années 30 la ça vaudrait jamais
l'expérience de vivre vous même ce qui
est de créer votre propre monnaie en
fait ça vaudra jamais le fait de
comprendre l'économie en recréant
l'économie
si ce groupe de pionniers avaient
étaient pas économiste c15 la du départ
il avait quand même un point commun est
d'ailleurs philippe l'inde est l'un des
fondateurs il aimait bien dire nos
projets ils sont un peu technique
beaucoup économique et passionnément
humain en fait c'était plutôt ça leur
spécialité l'humain l'ouverture aux
autres le respect de la différence et
pour moi dans la vie de la monnaie
autrement il ya une histoire qu'ils
montrent bien c'est celle de sophie qui
est arrivé dans le mouvement un peu par
hasard c'est un peu à la vie de la
lumière elle est rentrée c'est un peu
comme ça que ça s'est passé et puis
petit à petit comme ça deux ans après
elle a été élue au conseil
d'administration de l'association
elle connaissait pas bien les rouages de
la vie associative et elle s'est
retrouvée dans un univers plutôt
masculin et avec quand même des fortes
personnalités
mais le groupe i il a juste pris le
temps de l'accueillir en fait sophie
pour moi c'est un très bon exemple ça
restera toujours celle qui s'est servi
de toutes les occasions pour utiliser
les règles de vie que le groupe s'était
donné à lui-même par exemple sophie elle
a dit stop quand ça allait trop vite
pour elle comme ça elle a osé l'ouvrir
alors qu'elle était là depuis pas très
longtemps pour proposer les idées
qu'elle avait elle a intégré les règles
du débat et elle a pris des décisions et
voté des décisions avec lesquels des
fois elle n'était pas d'accord
elle y a consenti parce que c'était
possible pour elle dans ce cadre là et
du coup elle a accueilli ceux qui sont
arrivées derrière elle comme elle avait
été accueillie et la confiance est là ce
qu'il faut quand même réalisé c'est que
ces deux à trois cents à l'échelle de
notre petite ville c'est deux à trois
cents accordeur qui rejoignent chaque
année ce projet là et ces dix à quinze
entreprises
dix à quinze professionnels par mois qui
rejoignent les l'efs
en fait toute l'énergie de ce groupe
était concentré sur le fait de causer de
débattre de rassembler des dizaines puis
des centaines puis des milliers de
citoyens mais assez vite ce qui est
apparu c'est qu' il y avait quand même
de grosses différences l'école n'étaient
pas les mêmes chez les uns chez les
autres
bah oui tout simplement les commerçants
il fonctionne pas comme des associations
ou les élus ils se rassemblent pas dans
les mêmes endroits que les bénévoles les
militants il communique pas en direction
des entreprises
c'est mûri ces petites différences là ça
finissait par sembler un peu comme des
murs infranchissables qui empêchaient
les gens de se rendre compte que en fait
les enjeux ils sont les mêmes parce
qu'ils partagent avant tout le même
territoire il habite au même endroit et
puis à y regarder d'un peu plus près non
en fait on s'est rendu compte que ces
murs il était pas si épais que ça qu'en
fait vous savez ça peut être un peu
genre d espèce de petit cloisons en
placo finalement assez fine un peu du
même genre que celle qui m'empêche de
cause et avec mon voisin matin ou de
brand content que ma boulangère à des
soucis de santé ou encore que le maire
de ma commune
en fait il à ses enfants dans la même
école que les miens quoi bref des murs
ou en fait
c'est pas très compliqué de faire tomber
quoi bah oui parce que en fait ce que
s'est dit le groupe sait pourquoi mais
pourquoi dans le monde dans lequel on
vit il faudrait que toute la vie toute
la vie pendant des siècles et des
siècles les associations ne s'occupe que
de l'humain les entreprises ne fassent
que de l'argent et les élus ne fasse que
de la politique
no money là à nous nos banques elles
recouvrent ces trois dimensions
l'humain l'argent et la politique
alors du coup on n'avait pas le choix
c'est mûr il fallait qu'on les fasse
tomber est bon on a réussi on est quand
même un peu content on a rassemblé des
gens on les a embarqués dans l'aventuré
puis on a fini par se rassembler place
de l'hôtel de ville pas très loin d'ici
en novembre 2014 pour la première mise
en circulation
les élèves en monnaies locales alors on
est arrivé avec nos vélos là et des
sacoches pleines de billets tout neuf
c'est un peu froid on a fait couler du
café on a installé des comptoirs des
changes
les élus étaient là les commerçants
évidemment aussi bref qu'on avait
préparé une toute petite fête voilà à
notre échelle mais est on avait été tout
ce qu'il fallait on avait mis des
articles dans la presse on avait
communiqués depuis longtemps savais que
c'était un projet qui était attendu mais
on avait quand même tous le trac on
avait tous une même trouille c'était que
personne ne vienne et puis et bien en
l'espace de quelques heures la place
elle s'est rempli et c'est près 300
personnes ils sont venus et qui ont
échangé leurs euros on a mis en
circulation
dix mille élèves en trois heures de
temps
les sourires là ils se répondent et sur
la place aussi vite que les billes et
puis ben nous avec un peu de recul
quelques années plus tard on se dit que
si nos monnaies locales est l ont
toujours pas révolutionner l'économie
elles nous ont prouvé au moins une chose
c'est que aujourd'hui il n'y a pas que
la peur et l'impuissance qui soit
contagieuse non la joie le plaisir
l'envi mais le sont encore plus merci
[Applaudissements]